In 1951, doctors took a tissue sample from
a poor, dying black woman that was given to
researchers without her knowledge or permission.
The HeLa cells, named for the patient’s
first and last name, acted differently than
other cells in the lab — they were hardier,
and replicated at an amazing rate.
They also didn’t die.
Cultivation of HeLa launched a revolution
in biomedical research and a multibillion-dollar
industry.
The cells were sold all over the world, and
led to important advances to fight humankind’s
deadliest diseases, including polio, HIV,
and cancer.
No one, aside from the patient’s doctors
and lead researchers knew the origins of the
HeLa cells — not her name, or anything else
about her life.
Two decades passed before this mystery woman
was revealed.
And more years still, before her family had
answers to their burning questions.
Today, we examine the woman behind the notorious
and immortal HeLa cells: Henrietta Lacks.
Early Life
On August 1, 1920, Eliza Lacks Pleasant gave
birth to a baby girl, Loretta, in a shack
at the end of dead-end road in Roanoke, Virginia.
At some point during her life Loretta changed
her name to Henrietta, though no one knows
when or why.
The shack, overlooking the train depot, was
the young girl’s home until her mother tragically
died.
Henrietta was four years old.
Eliza passed from this life to the next during
childbirth with her tenth baby, leaving her
husband Johnny a widow.
Unable to care for all the children, he sent
them away to live with family, 125 miles southeast
from Roanoke in southern Virginia.
The Lacks family lived in the town of Clover,
just past Difficult Creek on the banks of
the River of Death.
It sounds like a bad omen, but in the 1920s
it looked a lot like most small towns in rural
Virginia.
On the outskirts, fields of tobacco and old
plantation houses dotted the rolling hills.
And on Main Street down the dusty road, the
town buzzed with life.
There was a movie theater, grocery store,
post office, shops, restaurants, and a train
depot.
Henrietta wouldn’t recognize the town today;
Clover lost so many residents by the late
1990s it’s official town charter was revoked.
In the last census in 2010, the total population
had dwindled to a mere 438.
When Johnny came to town in 1924, Henrietta
and her nine brothers and sisters had to be
divided up amongst the relatives.
No one could take all ten children.
Henrietta ended up living with her grandfather,
Tommy Lacks, in a four-room log cabin called
the home-house.
Generations of Lackses had lived and died
there, buried in the small family plot Henrietta
could see out her window.
Formerly slave quarters, the home-house was
a simple structure with no electricity or
indoor plumbing, only gas lanterns and water
that Henrietta hauled up from the creek below.
Tommy was already caring for another grandchild,
nine-year old “Day” Lacks when Henrietta
came to live at the home-house.
The children shared a room, and worked every
day together planting and harvesting the tobacco,
and tending to the animals and garden.
After the day’s work, they sometimes swam
in the swimming hole, had bonfires at night,
and played ring around the rosy with their
cousins.
Once a month during harvest grampa Tommy and
the cousins headed to South Boston, to the
second largest tobacco market in the nation,
to sell their crop.
It was a time they all looked forward too
even if the market wasn’t a safe place for
children with its free-flowing booze, prostitution,
and the occasional murder.
At the home-house, Henrietta awoke every morning
at four o’clock to milk the cows and feed
the pigs.
When she was finished her morning chores,
she walked two miles to the schoolhouse for
colored children, past the white school where
children threw rocks at her and called her
names.
Jim Crow laws segregated blacks from whites,
and they remained in place until 1964.
In the short 31 years of her life, it was
all she knew.
By sixth grade, Henrietta walked to the schoolhouse
one last time.
Like Day and the other Lackses, she dropped
out to work in the tobacco fields.
“Lovey Dovey” Woman
Few public photos of Henrietta Lacks exist
-- the most well-known is a striking image
from a 1970s Rolling Stone article of a smiling,
smartly-dressed woman in a skirt, suit jacket,
and open toe sandals.
Her hands are firmly placed on her hips, and
her walnut eyes glimmer at the camera.
She looks self-assured with a hint of mischief
spread out in her grin.
It’s obvious, even by today’s standards,
Henrietta was beautiful.
She was the envy of other women, and desirable
to all the men around her.
It wasn’t only her beauty that attracted
people to Henrietta.
Her cousin “Cootie” described her as “lovey
dovey” — as kind as she was pretty — always
taking care of family and friends in need.
As a child, Cootie had been stricken with
polio and Henrietta took care of him when
it got bad.
Everyone who knew her, remembers Henrietta
as a gentle caregiver and a strong woman.
Even when cancer was spreading inside her
body, she didn’t make a fuss or draw attention
to herself.
Very few people knew, until the end, how she
suffered.
Henrietta had no shortage of men vying for
her affection as a young woman.
Henrietta chose Day, her cousin with whom
she shared a bedroom and had spent countless
hours with since the age of four.
They had their first baby, a boy named Lawrence,
out of wedlock when Henrietta was barely fourteen
years old.
He was born on the home-house floor, like
his father and numerous cousins, aunts and
uncles, and grandparents before.
Another Lacks baby, Elsie, was born four years
later.
Eventually Henrietta and Day said their vows
in a private marriage ceremony on April 10,
1941.
She was 21 and he was 25.
Turner Station
By the winter of 1941, the country was at
war and small tobacco farms including Henrietta
and Day’s, were barely making enough to
make ends meet.
But to the north, there was opportunity in
the booming factories, as demand for steel
increased.
A great migration of black families came to
Turner Station, Maryland, leaving behind the
southern farms.
At Bethlehem Steel’s Sparrow Point in Baltimore
County, a black man could make up to eighty
cents an hour — the most any of the Lackses
had seen.
In the factories, black men took the jobs
white men rejected and they were exposed to
a host of toxic chemicals, including asbestos.
When the men finished their shifts and returned
home, the toxins were shared with their wives
and children through their clothes.
At the urging of a Lacks’ cousin who was
doing well for himself at Sparrow Point, Day
and Henrietta moved with their babies to Turner
Station, starting a new life.
Other cousins made the transition too, including
Henrietta’s close friend Sadie.
The city was a change for the Lackses but
they adjusted and had fun.
After cleaning, cooking, and taking care of
the children, Henrietta and Sadie would put
their dancing shoes on and sneak out until
the wee hours.
The two women boogied, laughed, and had a
great time.
And, when they weren’t dancing, Henrietta,
Sadie, and Sadie’s sister Margaret played
Bingo in Henrietta’s living room.
Turner Station was new and exciting but Henrietta
preferred the country.
Whenever she could, she rode the train back
to Clover to work in the fields, or churn
butter on the home-house porch.
It was here her eldest daughter, Elsie, was
at ease.
Elsie had inherited her mother’s good looks
but was born “special,” unable to speak
or talk.
She made chirps and caw sounds like the birds
and sometimes flailed her arms in front of
her face.
Years later it was understood Elsie has epilepsy,
and cognitive, developmental delays that left
her unable to communicate.
No one knew exactly what went on in her pretty
head.
At home in Turner Station, Elsie was known
to occasionally run out into the street screaming.
By the time Henrietta was pregnant with her
fifth baby, Elsie had grown stronger, and
this made it near impossible for her mother
to care for her.
To make life easier, doctors recommended Henrietta
commit Elsie to the Crownsville State Hospital,
formerly the Hospital for the Negro Insane.
Believing the doctors’ knew best, Henrietta
institutionalized her daughter.
Years later, family members said “a part
of Henrietta died the day she left Elsie at
Crownsville.”
Henrietta routinely visited her daughter once
a week at the hospital before becoming ill.
And after Henrietta died, no one went to Crownsville
to see Elsie again.
“A Knot Inside”
Henrietta was certain there was something
wrong a year and a half before her official
cervical cancer diagnosis.
She shared her worry with her cousins Sadie
and Margaret, saying there was a “knot inside”
and explaining how, “It hurt somethin awful
— when that man want to get with me.
Sweet Jesus aren’t them but some pains.”
The women poked at her stomach over and over
and felt nothing.
Maybe it was a baby growing inside, they suggested.
To be sure nothing was seriously wrong, her
cousins tried to convince Henrietta to see
a doctor but she didn’t.
And about a week later, Henrietta found out
she was pregnant.
The ladies reassured her it was just the baby
making her feel funny but Henrietta wasn’t
convinced.
Nevertheless, she didn’t bring it up again
with Sadie and Margaret and the women never
mentioned the conversation with anyone else.
Henrietta carried her fifth baby to full-term,
and a soon after Joe was born, Henrietta was
not feeling any better.
One day, alone in the bathroom, she slipped
into the bathtub and reached inside herself.
She could feel “the knot,” and told Day
she needed to go see the doctor.
On a referral from a local physician, Henrietta
went to Johns Hopkins Hospital to seek answers.
At this point, Henrietta thought the doctors
would “fix her right up.”
On January 29, 1951, Day drove Henrietta with
their three small children, 20 miles from
Turner Station to Johns Hopkins.
Johns Hopkins was not only a hospital, it
was a renowned medical research center.
It also had a public ward, serving patients
who were too poor to afford treatment — many
of whom were black.
In the 1950s, under discriminatory segregation
laws in the U.S., black patients could be
turned away at hospitals, doctor’s offices,
and clinics that served white patients.
Sometimes the consequences were dire, including
death.
Johns Hopkins was Henrietta’s best, and
only, real option for diagnosis and treatment
of cervical cancer.
While Day sat in the car with their small
children, waiting for Henrietta to return,
she met Dr. Howard Jones, the gynecologist
on duty.
In the exam room, he reviewed her medical
history and listened to Henrietta describe
the lump she felt inside her.
When Jones examined her, he found a hard mass
about the size of a nickel.
The tumor was the color of “grape Jell-O,”
exactly in the spot Henrietta said it would
be.
Decades later in his nineties, Jones recalled
never seeing anything like Henrietta’s tumor
during his years practicing medicine — not
before or since.
During the exam, Dr. Jones cut a tiny sample
of the tumor to test, and confirm what he
suspected was cancerous.
Then he sent Henrietta back home to Turner
Station to await the results.
Jones thought it was odd Henrietta had a full-term
baby just a few months prior, with no notes
mentioning the tumor, or any abnormalities
of the cervix listed in her chart.
It was unlikely physicians would have missed
seeing it, which meant it must have grown
at an alarming rate.
A few days later, Henrietta received the results
back from the lab, “Epidermoid carcinoma
of the cervix, Stage I.”
Growing “Like Crabgrass”
In 1951, it was standard practice to conduct
research on public ward hospital patients
without consent.
Explicit permission, or “informed consent,”
from patients wasn’t a term that was coined,
and no ethical or legal standard existed in
the U.S. for obtaining it.
At Hopkins, the then-leading cervical cancer
expert in the world, and Dr. Jones’ boss,
Richard TeLinde, believed that since the patients
were treated free of charge, the research
was a form of payment for the hospital’s
services.
When Henrietta went in for her exam, a sample
from Henrietta’s tumor was sent to George
Gey’s lab, the head of tissue culture research
at Hopkins, without her knowledge.
For years Gey had been trying unsuccessfully
to grow, and keep alive, human cells outside
the body in petri dishes.
Culturing cells allowed scientists to test
their response to all kinds of drugs, diseases,
and conditions in order to understand how
the human body would react.
And doing so didn’t cause harm to patients.
When Henrietta went to Hopkins, an agreement
was already in place to provide Gey’s research
lab with patients’ cancerous tumor samples,
primarily to be used in studies to prove TeLinde’s
theories.
TeLinde was a believer that of the two types
of cervical cancer, the non-invasive variety
(carcinoma in situ), could spread and become
deadly.
This was contrary to what the majority of
researchers thought at the time, and physicians’
practice followed this conclusion — treating
only the invasive cancers aggressively.
He had another motive for his research using
cells too — TeLinde wanted to reduce the
number of “unjustifiable hysterectomies”
by detecting what wasn’t cervical cancer
at all.
The PAP smear test, used to identify changes
to a woman’s cervical cells, was developed
only a decade earlier.
But, few physicians could interpret the results
and treat patients accordingly.
In extreme cases, a woman needing only antibiotics
to clear up a minor infection, might have
her entire uterus removed in a surgical procedure.
When Gey’s lab assistant Mary received Henrietta’s
tissue sample, she had every reason to believe
the cells, if they lived at all, would die
within a few days.
She was eating lunch, and decided to finish
her sandwich first.
So far, even with Gey’s standards, meticulous
process, and emphasis on sterilization, his
lab had little success with growing human
cells.
When Mary got to work on Henrietta’s cancer
cells, she carefully and precisely sliced
the samples with steady hands, mixed the media
the cells would need to grow, and labeled
them “HeLa” — for the first two letters
of Henrietta’s first and last names.
Then, she left them alone, not expecting much.
By the next morning to Mary’s surprise,
Henrietta’s cells had divided, and in the
days ahead, HeLa cells kept making copies
of themselves.
They grew unlike any cells before, and expanded
into as much space as Mary would give them.
Gey was ecstatic the cells were growing “like
crabgrass” and soon, among researchers,
word was out about the amazing HeLa cells.
Everyone knew the implications for furthering
biomedical research, and this was Gey’s
goal.
Soon, he began sending HeLa cells to any scientist
interested in using them for their own studies.
Death
Henrietta’s treatment for cervical cancer
was radium, a radioactive metal that glows
blue and is highly toxic.
In the early twentieth century, upon radium’s
discovery, it was hailed as a miracle to cure
all kinds of ailments.
Radium kills cancer cells...but it can burn
skin from a person’s body in high enough
quantities.
Being radioactive, radium also causes cancer.
In 1951, the radium treatment for cervical
cancer involved placing tubes inside the patient
next to the affected area.
Common side effects include nausea, vomiting,
weakness, and anemia.
If Henrietta experienced any of these, she
didn’t let on or seem sick.
After treatments started, Henrietta finally
told the same cousins she confided in about
“the knot” inside her.
She didn’t want anyone to worry, but the
frequent visits to Johns Hopkins would mean
she would be away and people would wonder
why.
Initially the radium treatments seemed to
work and doctors recorded the tumor had vanished.
As therapy progressed Henrietta didn’t feel
better, and to her horror, her abdomen turned
from soft brown to black as coal.
One day she lifted up her shirt and showed
Sadie and Margaret, and said it felt as though
“the blackness be spreading all inside.”
The radium treatments didn’t cure Henrietta’s
cancer.
By the fall of 1951, her body was full of
tumors — in her diaphragm, bladder, cervix,
kidneys, and lungs and she was in excruciating
pain.
She lay in bed at Johns Hopkins and scream
out like it was “the devil of pain itself.”
Between the treatments and the cancer, Henrietta
was weak and her kidneys were no longer flushing
out dangerous toxins in her blood.
She had to receive numerous transfusions.
The doctors tried different medications to
ease her suffering, including morphine, which
didn’t touch the pain.
On one desperate attempt, the doctors even
injected alcohol into her spine but nothing
seemed to work.
All anyone could do was sit beside her bed
and pray.
Henrietta’s sister Gladys was at her bedside
the night she succumbed to cancer.
Knowing her time had come, Henrietta made
her sister promise to take care of her kids
and whispered through tears, “Don’t you
let anything bad happen to them children when
I’m gone.”
At 12:15 a.m. on October 4, 1951, Henrietta
Lacks took her last breath and died in her
hospital bed.
Her body was sent back to Clover, and buried
in the family plot in an unmarked grave next
to her mother.
Importance of HeLa
The importance of Henrietta’s cells cannot
be overstated.
Through this immortalized, continuously cultured
cell line, cancer research has advanced, vaccines
have been developed, gene mapping has taken
place, and treatments of various diseases
have been studied and undertaken.
HeLa cells have even been put into space on
missions with both Americans and Russians,
were tested against an atomic bomb, and were
the first human cells to be cloned.
Perhaps the most well-known advances using
HeLa occurred soon after Henrietta’s death,
in the midst of a polio epidemic.
The virus was sweeping the country and parents
feared for their children’s lives.
In late summer, dubbed “polio season”
public swimming pools were shut down and officials
warned the virus could spread by sitting too
close to others at movie theaters.
By 1952, 60,000 children were infected and
thousands were paralyzed.
A vaccine was in development by Jonas Salk,
but he needed a way to test it in a lab on
a grand scale before injecting children.
HeLa provided the perfect opportunity.
Soon, the HeLa Project at Tuskegee University
began growing the cell line, employing mostly
black women lab technicians.
Tuskegee’s mass-production of HeLa would
serve as the first of its kind.
And, it helped launch a multibillion-dollar
industry when the first commercial cell culture
operation began using Tuskegee’s model in
an old Fritos factory in Bethesda, Maryland.
While this groundbreaking biomedical research
was taking place, only a handful of people
could trace the HeLa cell line origins back
to a poor, 31-year old black woman with cervical
cancer.
Two decades would pass before the name, Henrietta
Lacks, was finally released to the public.
The Lacks Family
For many years, members of the Lacks family
never knew how Henrietta’s cells were used
to advance medical research and when her name
finally became public, there were many questions
left unanswered.
The children, especially her daughter Deborah,
was “too young to remember” her mother
and longed to know what she was like, what
her favorite color was, and whether or not
she breastfed her.
Not knowing, and not understanding how her
mother’s cells could still be living after
her death was terrifying and caused the family
great anxiety and pain.
Her sons, and husband Day, were mostly angry
with Johns Hopkins, the doctors, and George
Gey. Day never gave the hospital permission
to use his wife’s cells and it didn’t
seem right, or fair, that people were making
millions of dollars from selling them while
members of the family couldn’t even afford
health insurance.
Hopkins has made public statements that the
hospital has never directly profited from
HeLa and at the time, no federal regulations
were in place for obtaining permission to
use Henrietta’s cells for research.
A book published in 2010 by author Rebecca
Skloot and a movie starring Oprah Winfrey
has recently brought greater attention to
the woman behind the “immortal” HeLa cells,
raising ethical questions for the world to
ponder.
For now, over sixty years after her death,
Henrietta’s cells live on and continue to
provide us with immeasurable value in the
fight to cure and eradicate disease.
For that, we can be grateful and finally know
a little bit more about the woman, Henrietta
Lacks.